i do want to ask you
about video games really quick as a
small tangent because you said this
really interesting idea of blizzard
being centralized control
is it possible to have items in the game
that are not controlled by blizzard
sure being controlled in a decentralized
fashion that you can
like what is it the grandfather sword in
diablo
hmm what was it really somebody was
criticizing me i said i was saying all
these kinds of nice things about diablo
3 and they said diablo 2
resurrected is coming out they need to
check it out there's a lot of
there's a lot of cameras we both know
that diablo 2 is far better than
that's what they're saying this is the
war that they're having okay so
i'll we'll play it's coming out soon
i'll play it fine
but nevertheless those items are owned
by blizzard
is there is it possible to create video
games
where items are owned by the people like
outside of blizzard
and uh do you think
in like a half century from now we will
all live in those games and we'll forget
the physical space even
well yeah that's definitely possible i
look at cryptokitties that's a great
example of that
can you explain what cryptokitties is
well it's basically just a video game
that kind of lives on a blockchain and
the
creatures within the game can breed with
each other and create new cryptokitties
and you can own them
just like like like some sort of
dystopian tamagotchi with lots of money
behind
but but anyway you know the thing is
those assets actually have
a blockchain based representation and so
whether
the infrastructure that hoists up that
game off-chain goes on or off
because that ledger exists outside of
the game any person can come in
replicate it restore it and you know
turn it back on
uh sans intellectual property so yeah
it's completely possible to
to break your architecture up where you
have a notion of
the player part and then you have a
notion of the experience part
and you can interchange experiences
almost like you do cascading style
sheets or something for you know have
different presentations and the
ownership of the
underlying layers the players so yeah
that's definitely doable and frankly
that's what's going to happen
in the gaming world because there's so
much value in that i mean everybody
wants play and
you know right now the model is you make
a game you sell licenses
and you you have a huge surge of people
at the beginning of the game buying the
video
game and then you have this long tail
but you've gotten almost 95
of your value in the first six months
you have a huge churn rate the odds are
the vast majority people won't be
playing the game within 12 months
but if you can create an interactive
game where there's an actual economy
inside the game
then you have eve online or second life
or any of these things where you have
people playing for 10 years and there's
like people buying virtual real estate
and all these other things
you as a game developer actually don't
have to create a lot of content
so your long tail gets a lot fatter and
it generates a lot more revenue and your
cost of operating system is fairly fixed
or diminishing
so the economics align for doing exactly
what you're what you're talking about i
think it'll get done
well i i just saw recently sort of this
calculation that people played uh
wow and fortnite for 140 billion
hours yeah so and that's without the
economic
incentives there so do you think it's
possible that like most of our economy
in the future
will be putting up people playing video
games essentially
like okay so one one vision of the
future especially with ai and automation
that people
like um that would get wealthy and
wealthier there's this kind of rising
gdp for the entire world
and then people are losing their jobs
but they're still are well off enough to
be able to have
a high quality of life so we're all
looking for meaning and the meaning will
find just by playing video games and now
there's this
extra levels like you can be a bill
gates within a video game world in the
digital world as well as the physical
world
uh is that do you think that's the
future you just want to have the west
world if you can't tell the difference
does it matter
utter um did you ever interview yaval
harari was here
not yet eventually well yeah but you
know i guess you know homo diaz that's
kind of like the road map there right
this hedonistic dystopia where everybody
just lives
wired into some simulation and i there's
some movies about that ready player one
and
um the other one was surrogate and so
forth so yeah it was
hollywood has certainly visualized what
this could be but you know i i'm not so
pessimistic in that respect um i do
believe that the video game world is
evolving at an amazing pace if you look
at where unreal is at
is just incredible the latest unreal
engine and within one or two more
ticks of that clock the iterations so
five to ten years
the photo realism will be so good that
it'll be
hard to distinguish between real life
and uh
and video games and you know the
hardware is almost there
so the question is then when you have
photorealistic experiences where you've
you've successfully traversed the
uncanny valley to a point where it's
good enough
then uh will virtual reality be more
desirable than
actual reality and for the vast majority
of people the answer is probably yes
because actual reality is tough it's
hard you know
but then your knowledge of that you live
in a virtual
world actually becomes a problem for you
so there's going to be this kind of
sad dark industry where people try to
create amnesia
where they're not aware that they're
inside the virtual world and so that's
that's it why is it sad i mean it's
almost like uh
because you know it's it's not real but
if if you could
forget that it's not real then you
believe what you're experiencing is real
yeah but yeah so what you forget like
you forget all the ugly parts of life
which is the physical
the meat space and then you usually get
to enjoy video games but it's always
lurking in the back of your mind that
you're in the matrix well you have to
not be in the major it's
just why the the bald dude in the matrix
was like i want to be rich and have a
beautiful wife and eat a steak every day
you know he didn't want to know he was
in the matrix so you would take the red
pill not the blue pill well no no
hang on it depends on how good the
virtual world is
that's what i'm trying to tell you is i
mean isn't that what most of the
beautiful experiences about
uh human life are is forgetting for a
moment
for time like the mess of it yeah i mean
that's what love is
you forget like all of a sudden
everything is beautiful
but like the reality is you're gonna
lose that person and most likely love
will fade
and no matter what even if it doesn't
you're both gonna be dead soon
jesus christ
so i'm taking the blue pill on that one
you went full ernest becker on me man
okay but you know right you know i get
what you're saying though and
actually but but then it begs the
question how do it goes back to the very
first question you asked in this
interview
which is like how do we know we're not
in a simulation or you know is this
is bostrom's concepts or these ideas
like real
well it's entirely possible that we are
and that we we desire to be
because the real world is horrifically
dystopian or bad or
maybe we actually don't exist we're
completely virtual and does it matter
and i'd argue that it probably doesn't
at um you know at some certain point if
you're at the end of your life in your
90s dying of cancer
you know the fact that you can live out
being young healthy and 25
is probably a desirable thing and no one
would ever complain about that
where it becomes problematic is if the
vast majority of society
enters this virtual simulacra of reality
and as a consequence nothing works
because there's no one to do anything
society falls apart in that respect you
know there's no
desire to do anything in the real world
innovation stops the desire to actually
do real work stops because you're always
inside this
virtual economy so i don't know it's
it's it's an interesting question
but you know drawing it back more to
where we're at today
um the evolution factors are there you
know vr is evolving at a very rapid rate
uh the game engines are just incredible
today and they're really doing amazing
things and
there seems to be an overwhelming desire
for people to escape
the harshness of where they live just by
evidence by how many billions of hours
have been spent playing video games
people still play skyrim
yeah yeah it's probably my favorite game
of the whole elder scrolls series
but you know it's it's fascinating
because smart contracts is actually the
mechanism by which we take a lot of the
meat space stuff and move it to the
digital world
so that we're this is the all the stuff
we've been talking about is
really probably the mechanisms which
take us there
which uh i i find that world not
dystopian i find the world quite utopian
because there's so many opportunities to
create beautiful experiences
you